[Music]
you just had a baby boy yes I did he's
how old he's six weeks old okay and what
a mistake a mistake I mean like the
greatest thing that ever happened to my
wife I'm on the fence about him you
shouldn't go home no yeah no it's great
it's amazing I mean you know yeah it's
it's amazing but um it's it's also a
horrible decision you know like what are
you talking about well like your life is
over I mean you're like yeah yeah you're
like so over yeah for the first three
months like he gives me nothing
he gives me nothing I work so hard I'm
all day like you know hanging he just
stares at me like looking through he's
like looking at my babies like being at
a Hollywood party he's always like
[Laughter]
there's someone more important he's
always like oh my god I think Bill
hader's over there now okay well yeah
you said it's your life silver what's
the biggest change in your life since
you've had this baby boy well there's a
couple set I think the the first change
would be how much you fight with your
wife when you have a new baby like I
told my friend the other day whose thing
about having a baby I said make sure
that the person you're having a baby
with has absolutely no characteristics
that annoy you that's easy because even
the slightest the smallest tick yeah you
get to have those good whisper fights oh
the whisper play you'll see kids don't
do it yeah and it's like pretty much
having a baby is like consistently
putting together an Ikea entertainment
center except that if you like put the
door on the wrong way it'll die
[Applause]
the show is happy endings I was
wondering how much good will the tuxedo
would lend me he did very well into the
dead baby jokes is where the
[Laughter]